Welcome back everyone it's Charlie! This
is going to be the flash season 6 episode
14 video Wally West is back there were a
whole bunch of Easter eggs including
some other big characters that came back
in some big comic book twists if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing a
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your biggest theory about what's going
on with reverse flash in the speedforce
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet obviously we'll do top
10 and Easter eggs as we go along
and there were a lot of Easter eggs
starting with number 10
welcome back Wally West so they give him
the cold open the entire cold open to
kind of show you how he's changed since
the last time we saw him a couple
seasons ago it has been a hot minute
since wally west has been on the show
they introduced the rich couple that are
on their way to santa presa which is a
comic book location they referenced it
when cisco was making his map right
after a crisis on Infinite Earths he's
like this is what Earth prime looks like
all these different comic book places
that used to be on different earths are
now on the same earth you see Wally used
the Speed Force in slightly different
ways than you've seen Barry or any other
speedster use it it's a big comic book
Easter Egg for Zen Wally west from the
Mark Waid comics so that was during that
Wally West era after he'd become the
main version of the flash after a comic
book crisis on Infinite Earths no less
so Wally being super zen talking about
Buddhism all these lessons that he's
learned this is them combining a lot of
things from the Wally West era of the
comics with this version of Wally West
so number nine Wally West's new Zen
speed force connection he also talks to
Barry during the episode about how he
connects to the Speed Force very
literally he says that it's not like him
speaking to an aspect of his mother the
way that Barry does speaking to an
aspect of a Speed Force wormhole alien
that just chooses to look like his
mother to make him feel more comfortable
Wally just hears a voice in his head it
also shows him potential futures because
remember the Speed Force exists outside
of space-time later in the episode he
says that he saw potential futures with
his children from the comics so Wally
West in the comics eventually gets
married to Linda Park they have twins
just like Barry and iris eventually have
twins in the comics I guess twins just
run in the flash family he also says
that he saw a future version of Nora
become the main version of the flash in
the future now keep in mind that this
was
or crisis on Infinite Earths because why
said lately things have been off and
they could have explored that through
the course of the episode but it is
really cool to see him use speed force
constructs to create those flowers so
eventually at some point berry will
probably learn to do a version of that
in a slightly different way all this
will make sense when they pay off the
death of the Speed Force arc because the
title of the episode is literally the
death of the Speed Force which is the
big comic book arc that they just did in
the flash rebirth comics number eight
cisco comes back to referencing Aquaman
in Atlantis so apparently Aquaman is now
on earth prime too. It makes sense that
they're combining all the Justice League
characters under earth one you have a
version of Batman that at least used to
be around on earth one there's a version
of Superman that we know now we still
need to find out where Wonder Woman is
hanging out because if we have pretty
much the entire Justice League we know
that there's a famous Kira that they
visited on the show before on legends of
tomorrow we just never actually seen a
version of Wonder Woman on the TV show
Lynda Carter has guest-starred on
Supergirl but she wasn't playing a
version of Wonder Woman she was playing
a different character
he's burning that hat so they make a
Crocodile Dundee joke then number seven
we meet the new version of the turtle
turtle 2.0 which is this character so
they actually visualized her powers in a
slightly more comic book-y way which i
think is actually pretty cool they might
actually be getting into the
quote-unquote forces from the comics too
because the death of the Speed Force
comic book arc also gets into the
different forces that the flash family
learns about so the Speed Force the
negative Speed Force are just two
different of many different forces
there's the still force which is what
the turtle uses to stop time it's
basically his inertia based powers they
bring back the velocity ex from earlier
to this season they've refined a version
of velocity nine into velocity X it's a
little bit safer I guess but still
pretty dangerous but it's also going to
come in handy next week when they deal
with the new version of the Speed Force
that team flash is going to try and create
so I'll address that when I do a trailer
video tomorrow but then number six
you have Wally West versus Barry Allen
Wally finally confronts Barry over all
the crap that he pulled and all the
stuff has happened since crisis on
Infinite Earths this is your fault Barry
they really have it out during the
episode but it just reminds you of
flashpoint in all the flashpoint memes
that everyone was posting during flash
season 3 like oh that sure does look
like
time line be a shame if someone messed
it up so because Wally won't take Barry
back into the Speed Force just because
he's pissed at him number five
barry uses reverse flashes tachyon
enhancer that he helped him design to
enter the Speed Force again and just as
he's doing that they start setting up
the Nash Wells reverse flash twist so it
felt like the way they transitioned
between these different storylines was
actually really good because Wally says
you're going to have to go find someone
else to teach you how to get back into
the Speed Force they transition right to
Nash wells getting attacked by a version
of reverse flash in his mind space then
immediately after Barry hooking himself
into something that the reverse flash
helped him design so obviously reverse
flash is going to be a big part of how
Barry fixes the Speed Force but when he
goes back into the Speed Force he learns
what really happened is all this green
lightning is based on the specters
energy Early's they believe it is now no
one has told them anything different so
Barry's just going to go on believing that
it's all his fault because of what he
did during crisis in number four
Barry has to watch his mother die again
for I think the third or at least fourth
time on the show he's watched his mother
died several times while this is
happening Wally West is getting one of
the classic Joe West pep talks just
saying that you need to think about it
from Barry's perspective he's going to kill
himself over this trying to fix
everything
so eventually Wally comes back around on
it by the end of the episode it doesn't
blame Barry quite as much as much as you
want to make fun of Barry for messing
things up because he's usually the
person that causes as many problems as
he solves the way the writers are giving
him an out is they're saying that he did
this with the specters energy as a
measure of last resort you were trying
to save the multiverse it was the only
way it just them trying to make Barry
seem like he's not a total idiot for
what he did and while this is all
happening it culminates in number three
welcome back reverse flash Cisco goes to
see Nash wells to apologize to him but
by that time reverse flash has already
taken over his mind however they're
going to explain him existing within
Nash's mind space he's effectively taken
over his body but we learned that
because he's in Nash's body he doesn't
have his connection to the negative
Speed Force anymore or at least yet I'm
sure he'll find a way to reconnect that
because it seems like in the trailer
footage for next week's episode he is in
his reverse flash costume but it just
confirms
my theory about what they were setting
up in the previous episodes it just
seemed like they were setting up the
twist that it was going to be
Nashville's becoming reverse flash like
he was trapped inside his mind but his
more like reverse flashes consciousness
was trapped or connected to Wells
somehow because of what they did during
crisis so that also means that other
versions of Wells are probably trapped
inside his mind space because he saw the
other versions of Wells speaking to him
like Sherlock Wells I really like it
when they get into a crazy speedforce
mythology flash mythology so I think the
next couple of episodes are going to be
reverse flash heavy as they try to mess
with the Speed Force I'm really excited
about that but number two Wally West and
Barry versus the turtle so they do
another version of them running together
except this time Wally knows how to
phase so they can both face with the
building it just a callback to their
race a couple seasons ago during season
3 when Wally just became kid flash
didn't know how to phase yet so they
were racing down the street and Wally
had to run over the building while Barry
phased through and beat him this time
they phased through they're able to
eventually defeat the turtle but not
before Wally gets trapped in one of
those inertia bubbles they're able to
disable her powers using the velocity X
formula that they were vers engineered
and then after this we probably get one
of our most reverse flash pipeline
scenes we've ever gotten now normally
he's pretty vicious when he's talking to
Barry about what he wants to do I want
to kill you the same thing I always want
to do but this time he just lays it on
so thick I was like wow they were really
making reverse flash seem like a
psychopath way more than he's ever been
in the past
I think that's maybe because the amount
of episodes that I'll be around for will
be relatively limited it might not be
the entire rest of the season because
God speed is coming along later this
season but reverse flash knows about
what happened to the Speed Force because
as a speedster he can sense that the
Speed Force is dying I love the way he
calls it your puny Speed Force that's
why I made my own referring to the
negative Speed Force which also gives
Barry the idea at the post credits scene
so number one team flash is going to
try and make their own Speed Force like
reverse flash reverse engineering the
negative Speed Force what could possibly
go wrong in while all this is going on
the fake version of iris totally takes
out Camilla using the mirror gun but the
mirror gun is just sending Camilla into
the mirrored dimension so she'll play
show up inside the mirror dimension with
the real version of iris pretty soon
I almost forgot to talk about the black
flash so one of the big parts of the
comic book death of the Speed Force arc
with the different forces is the black
flash the black flash always acts to
protect the Speed Force so even though
they'll probably change it for the TV
show we might see the black flash come
back as Barry tries to mess with his own
speed force obviously he's not quite as
advanced in his science as the reverse
flashes
they'll probably derp super hard so
hopefully that'll be good story to slot
in and black flash to come back for it
because it's been a while since we've
seen that character and they're going
very heavy on Speed Force mythology the
back half of the season so it makes
sense that that would justify them
bringing back black flash at some point
so everyone let me know in the comments
if you spotted any big flash Easter eggs
in the episode that I didn't mention in
the video but there's going to be some big
Speed Force Flash mythology stuff
happening in the next couple of episodes
it's going to be a lot of fun
so I'll do a trailer video for all that
stuff tomorrow let me know if there's
any special bonus videos or if there's
any big questions you have about the
stuff that they're setting up or the
comic book stuff that they're
referencing with the different
quote-unquote forces but everyone click
here for that brand new teaser trailer
for the boys season 2 with the storm
front character and click here for that
brand new Black Widow trailer thank you
so much for watching everyone stay
awesome we'll see you guys tonight!